(whooshing)
- [Woman] Bobsledding is
a Winter Olympic sport
where you have your driver and you have
a brakeman, which is my position.
The brakeman is mainly
the engine to the sled.
We get it goin' as fast as possible.
(rustling)
(whooshing)
I am Aja Evans, and I'm
an Olympic bobsledder.
(dramatic orchestral music)
The track is about a mile
long, and full of twists
and turns, and it can get up to 90 miles an hour.
Th moment I zip up my speed suit,
I feel like a complete superhero.
It's almost like I here
the theme music in my head.
I'm ready to go.
(rattling)
(clattering)
(digital sound wave)
(beeping)
As we're going to track, pickin' up speed,
we start to pull about five Gs,
which is five times the force a gravity.
So, it's literally what a
fighter pilot experiences.
(rustling)
(nervous music)
It's like someone's jumping on you,
'cause out of nowhere, you just feel
all this pressure on your lower back.
(scraping)
It's a pretty noisy ride.
My head is rattling throughout the sled.
I'm tryin' to stay low.
(rustling)
As soon as it's over, I can inhale
and start breathin' again.
(sonic wave)